[Music]
well TVs number one comedy The Big Bang
Theory returns for an all-new episode
next Thursday but if you need something
to hold you over until then why not
check out star Johnny Galecki newest
comedy passion project living biblically
and we were first on the set I said can
I get an amen
don't milk it boy
Jr Ferguson stars as a man who decides
to change his life and live it entirely
by the Bible would you give up your
phone if God asked you to God would
never ask you to do that Johnny is
executive producing the show which is
based on a book he and Jay go way back
they knew each other as kids Chris
Rock's brother Tony also co-stars along
with the stalks Sara Gilbert she and
Johnny played a married couple on the
original Roseanne it's fantastic to work
with Sara again we've remained friends
and she was on she did a few episodes a
big bang early on a run if you could
just make my new lifestyle seem as
normal to her as possible that would
really help me out tremendously well try
but you look like Diane Keaton Johnny
says he hopes the comedy will inspire
conversations about faith and so far
it's already inspiring Jay in real life
I had a moment actually the other day
where I was driving here to work and a
guy that was angry at me for my driving
spit on my car and my instinct initially
was to catch up to him and and you know
do something back but I caught myself
because of this episode that we did and
I'm I didn't I didn't go up and tell him
I loved them but I just let him keep on
going and that's progress for me love
thy neighbor right well that sucks
so does Johnny think he could live by
the good word the cursing thing I would
have trouble with that's that's for sure
and back to the show star JR Ferguson is
no stranger to the CBS family he was 16
when he joined the 90s sitcom evening
shade opposite Bert Ralph and Marilu
Henner
[Music]